the director general of the World Health
Organization the wh his name is Tedros
adnam Gabus he saw elon's tweet and he
retweeted it and wrote this dear Elon
Musk I understand your perspective but I
respectfully disagree diversity equity
and inclusion are essential principles
that aim to promote fairness equal
opportunities and respect for all
individuals regardless of their
background or identity perspectives and
experience so on one hand he's saying
okay diversity Equity inclusion which we
know is based on judging people by race
right like no one's no one's debating
that so he's saying diversity equ
inclusion are important and then he's
saying respect for all individuals
regardless of their background or
identity except the whole thing is based
on judging people by their background
and identity